high schools across the u.s. are
boosting student access to college by
letting kids rack up college credit
while still in high school
the Indiana based 21st century charter
school offers the distinctive model
while 95% of high schoolers who earned
college credit do so via ap or similar
high school based programs 21c is
actually getting kids to campus this
approach is challenging 21c had to align
its schedule to local colleges handle
transportation costs and find funds for
textbooks and tuition plus there's a
skepticism as to whether high schoolers
can do college work but there are also
clear benefits getting kids on campus
pubs bridge a crucial psychological
barrier especially for first-generation
college goes students have earned more
than sixteen hundred college credits and
17 degrees all at no cost to their
families it's too early to suggest that
21 sees model works but it's a promising
practical strategy what do you think of
letting high schoolers take classes on
college campuses let us know in the
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI